Whoa!
It's a box fit for a king, it is.
As it should be.
We are delivering it to the King of Space
himself.
A real-life king? This could be my big chance
to grovel.
Ooh. Swanky dump.
Your delivery, my liege.
Now this guy knows how to grovel.
Yes!
At last, the portrait of my late wife has
arrived. Careful. It's delicate.
Infinita, Queen of Space.
Not even the finest macaroni artist could
capture your beauty.
Although this one did.
Hang it over there.
Oh, sorry.
It's my early onset sciatica.
Announcing His Royal Highness the Prince of
Space.
Allow me to help your elderly friend.
Wow. This absolute stud sure made me look
like a wimp, huh, Leela?
You guys straighten that together while I explain our loyalty
punch card program to His Majesty.